Okay, I got some serums that I fucking love.
Today's the first day I used them,
but I really fucking like them.
This is some revital lift.
I don't know what the fuck they are.
The point of this is
this is their vitamin C and caffeine.
I serum fucking love this.
Then I got their vitamin C,
E, and salicylic acid for the face to brighten.
Love that. And then I got this from Trader Joe's.
Hyaluronic acid.
I use that next.
Then just a regular moisturizer.
I'm at my boyfriend's house,
so this is the one I'm using.
But this is not the one I use at home,
but I do like this one.
And then before I go to bed,
I'm gonna put marula oil,
a really light coating.
Cause moisture,
moisture, moisture.
We don't wanna look like fried chicken.
We wanna look like the raw chicken.
And then aquaphor on top of that.
That's my plan.